Anna is with us in North Carolina hey
Hanna welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Jays thank you for taking my call
sure what's up so my husband we
completely cash flowed our wedding and
our honeymoon and all of our calls or
cash paid so I'm acting right now and
but we're both in school and my thing is
I even want to school for the past like
three years now but I've been going in
full credits because I've been paying
out of cash so my husband on the other
hand he took out loans so by next year
when he graduates he'll have around
three three thousand dollars to close
debt which is I'm completely debt-free
but since we're married now all that
jazz combined is it what are we
commanded our income and our bank
accounts and we're working through this
thing we're trying to pay it off - oh so
what my question is I'm wondering should
I take a break from my school in cash
and just take a break from school
completely to help pay off his loans
that so by graduation he can I my
graduation will be debt-free huh yeah
that's what I pray or at least a little
bit after he graduates weekend Mike
Kathy's life and then once with it when
does she graduate give or take about a
year like next year when do you graduate
I'd I don't graduate for another if I go
at the pace I'm at I don't graduate for
another three years okay and what are
you studying well on in ministry right
now so I'm I'm studying like a difficult
ounce allure ship and I work with
children ministry and I work in the
daycare but it's really not
it's like it's it's a is where I'm
working right now and I kind of went to
school because I was told that I needed
to go to school and I didn't really know
what I needed or wanted to do at the
time but it was one of those things that
people just told me just go to school
and figure it out so right now just
still trying to figure it out yeah well
that's a [ __ ] that's a horrible plan
yeah go to school and then figure it out
that's just a horrible plan whoever gave
you that advice isn't fool so the only
reason you would go to school would be
to get a degree that you're going to use
the knowledge from the degree to
increase your income yeah otherwise
you're going to school simply for the
acquisition of knowledge and which is
for sure a luxury so I don't hear that
I'm about to complete my degree which is
going to double my income in in three
years it's not going to do any of that
so yours is the acquisition of knowledge
just to be better informed in your
ministry but it's not going to change
your income situation at all am i
understanding correctly yes you're
completely because I worked and based on
that let's put less based on that let's
put the degree on hold okay because the
acquisition the getting of the degree
for you is a luxury because it's simply
adding depth to your ministry experience
it is not a an economic decision that
you're doing okay there's nothing wrong
with gathering knowledge for the you
know to add richness to your life but
you need to pay cash for that when your
family's out of debt right now this is
slowing down the yeah to get out of that
plan of your newly formed family due to
you being married what's your husband
studying my husband was also in the same
boat as I was he was told that he needed
to go to school so he did we both joined
a Christian a small Christian online
college and but he he doesn't play that
his degree is going to helping his
degree right now isn't counseling but he
works for medical supply company and
he's really believed in
he won't steal till I teach and he wants
to get hit faster than a doctor
eventually please they want to teach it
like a college level but he does it
right now we can't check because we hold
this figure all to cashflow the rest of
his college you know in that area so
what does he mean is he is he working
for you our job right now he's working
two jobs actually he he works a he works
a full-time job brings in about eighteen
sure and then he works a part-time job
on the weekends okay so what is your
household income today now that you're
married so our household income is
around thirty five between the two of
you yes and both of your working
full-time all right well I
but I was transferred so I cause I work
at a daycare used to work with the
preschoolers but now the after-school
age group because that job became very
very stressful for me and I feel more
passionate with the age group that I'm
in and however this age group that I
work with is a school schedule I had
high hours very so I work part-time
surveys full time those days I think you
need a new job here yeah you're not
making a living no and he's not making
much of one was what he's doing yeah so
you guys are starving that's part of
this part of the issue too so I think
you need guys need to lay out some
really clear career goals of exactly
where you want to be in five or ten
years and what education is going to be
required to get you there if any and but
but being in ministry does not require
that you be broke it does not require
that you become wealthy but it does not
require that you'd be broke and so
you're you know you need to have a path
by which you can make a living and if
you're gonna if you're going to be in
ministry in a place that cannot afford
to pay you then that's called
volunteering and you're gonna have to
have
mainstream mainstream jobs as well as
your side gig hustle ministry stuff
until your ministry can grow to support
you and it sounds like both of you have
got really big hearts and you're
desiring to serve God but you haven't
found ways to do that to feed your
family yet and so you may have to have
some mainstream jobs that are legitimate
good income producing jobs that allow
you the economic wiggle room then to
serve in the local church and to serve
in some of these ministries but but
working for them in working for you
right now you're starving to death so
we're gonna have to reset this and put a
new template in place that you guys go
with and then ascertain what education
is needed to do that but just generally
speaking you need to become more
educated well we all do but that's a
really dumb reason to go to college you
need to you know you need to have a
place that you're going with the
expenditure you're gonna spend the money
we need to get into a different place
because of it hey good question I
appreciate you joining us and I
appreciate your heart